bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
films nous sommes le 11 avril 2016 et
dont l'actualité locale aujourd'hui
alors qu'une nouvelle réunion sur la
ligne 18 du grand paris doit se tenir
dans quelques jours à guyancourt un
collectif de voisins-le-bretonneux
conteste la façon dont se déroule
enquête publique les raisons de leur
colère le réseau d'associations
musulmanes du sud des yvelines poursuit
son dialogue avec les élus notamment son
dîner annuel se tenait ce week end à
elancourt nous y reviendrons avec nos
invités en plateau il aura fallu quatre
ans de travaux de réhabilitation et de
rénovation pour que le donjon du 12e
siècle de houdan puisse ouvrir au public
c'est dorénavant chose faite
les images de ce monument et de la
soirée d'inauguration à la fin de ce
journal
dans l'actualité du jour également vie
locale avec cette fermeture du bureau de
la poste de coignières à l'antenne
située au centre commercial le village
accueillant plus assez de clients la
mise en place d'une agence postale
communale a été décidé installée à
l'accueil de la mairie est ouvert tous
les après-midi le guichet est tenu par
le personnel de la municipalité les
agents donc dû suivre une formation pour
assurer un franchissement des lettres et
des colis ou encore vente de timbres
pourquoi on avait anticipé donc cette
ouverture sur la mairie de coignières
c'était c'est aussi pour faciliter la
proximité des gens qui viennent à la
pause parce que ce n'est pas toujours
évident de se déplacer à 5 km le bureau
de poste central est temps mort pas donc
on a privilégié cette proximité au sein
de notre commune et en mairie qui est
quand même centrale
nous donnons cette possibilité donc aux
personnes de coignières pour venir
maintenant faire leurs démarches de tout
service public de la poste dans notre
mairie voilà transport à présent alors
que la société du grand paris à lancer
une enquête publique sur la future ligne
18 des vies sinois font part de leur
mécontentement depuis plusieurs semaines
le tracé actuel du métro qui devrait
passer sous une cinquantaine
d'habitations de la commune également
sous une école primaire les a
passablement agacé les précisions avec
fanny bourdon
la ligne 18 qui devrait relier orly et
versailles chantiers d'ici 2030 ne fait
pas que des heureux
des habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux
sont inquiet du tracé actuel du métro
automatique
elle devrait passer sous leur habitation
dont le sol est déjà fragilisé le tracé
actuel présentation de la difficulté
d'une part il passe sous une zone
résidentielle alors que tout est fait
généralement pour éviter de passer sous
les habitations ce sont des habitations
qui se trouve sur un terrain argileux
parti rend sensible aux phénomènes de
retrait-gonflement des argiles qui
composaient déjà beaucoup de problèmes à
ces habitations donc le tunnel du métro
risquerait de provoquer des difficultés
complémentaires la société du grand
paris a lancé depuis le 21 mars dernier
une enquête publique sur le sujet 1300
remarques ont déjà été déposés sur
internet
de leur côté ils assurent que la
discussion est ouverte et qu'un tracé
alternatif peut être trouvés en cas de
litige
nos étudiants le les modifications de ce
tracé et les bureaux d'études que nous
employons sont en train de vérifier la
faisabilité de tracé qui ne passeraient
pas sous ce quartier de la bretonnière
donc
je crois que il est important que le
cette enquête publique permettent aux
habitants de s'exprimer
l' enquête publique se terminera le 26
avril d'ici là la société du grand paris
organisera une réunion jeudi prochain à
20h au pavillon pierre waldeck rousseau
de guyancourt l'objectif informer et
recueillir les remarques des habitants
de l'agglomération
nous passons à l'entretien de cette
édition et je reçois présent mourad
d'allier le président de l'association
alif membres du collectif des
associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
environs bonsoir à vous stéphane azou ni
président de l'association des musulmans
de maurepas bonsoir et bienvenue
également et puis tu mourras de bach
bouchard président de l'association
socio culturelle des musulmans de
saint-cyr-l'ecole fontenay le fleury par
donc soit bonsoir à vous nous allons
revenir sur le dîner annuel du cam 78
qui vient de se tenir le cam pour
collectif des associations musulmanes
qui se réunit chaque année avec ses
différents partenaires dont les élus on
va d'ailleurs en voir rapidement les
images de ce dîner qui se tenait ce
week-end du côté d'el en cours tout
d'abord à quoi sert ce rendez vous c'est
un moment d'échangé aussi avec vos
différents partenaires oui c'est surtout
un moment d'échangé avec les différents
partenaires qu'on allait les élus locaux
aussi les acteurs socio économiques du
département
et puis aussi dans ce moment là on
essaye de joindre l'utile à l'agréable
on se retrouve donc autour d'un dîner
j'ai aussi on traite de questions
beaucoup plus sérieuse que l'on n'a pas
nécessairement le temps de traiter en
cours de l'année avec les agendas
respectifs qui sont très chargés on va
représenter peut-être le cam 78 le cam
qui existe depuis 2007 avec 13
associations qui le composent
à quoi sert la structure alors la
structure en fait le cam est une
association de fait donc toujours pas de
statuts déposés en tant que tel mais un
fonctionnement très très élaboré qui qui
perdure depuis une dizaine d'années
maintenant
au départ il y avait une
un groupe de sept associations qui se
sont réunis sur plusieurs questions mais
notamment la question essentielle du
sacrifice de l'aïd al adha
donc il ya eu un gros travail de fait
par ses membres fondateurs c'était pour
la mise en place d'un abattoir
on a besoin de l'abattoir dans le
département exactement d'un abattoir
mobile qui répond à condition de décence
et de salubrité nécessaires à ce genre
d'opération et à ce moment là donc avec
au départ une initiative de quelques
maires qui ont aidé notamment le maire
d'elancourt le maire de plaisir de
l'époque qui avait aidé à cette mise en
place de ce noyau de cette association
petit à petit ben il ya eu un groupe qui
s'est constitué qui s'est agrandie
aujourd'hui de 13 associations sur 12
communes et très tôt il y avait on
représentait déjà le grand saint quentin
en yvelines
on a plaisir les clayes-sous-bois
maurepas également voilà j'étais là bien
avant janvier 2016 et donc c'est toutes
ces questions là donc et aussi les
questions de partage de compétences
d'expérience qui nous aide à nous à
échanger à mieux structurer donc
l'exercice du culte pour les musulmans
dans la région de saint quentin en
yvelines et ses environs parce qu'on a
aussi l'association des musulmans de
rambouillet qui est présente
donc c'est vraiment tout le sud des
yvelines et la partie centrale
on va faire réagir peut-être les deux
autres associations qui représentent à
la fois maurepas et puis à
saint-cyr-l'ecole fontenay le fleury la
création du cam justement est ce besoin
des changes vous l'avez ressenti aussi
c'était nécessaire de venir échanger
d'échangés autour de devaux difficulté
de trouver des solutions communes aussi
oui en fait dès le départ de la création
de l'association demain on a essayé de
se rapprocher justement d'une quinte
parce que voilà quand quand vous débutez
vous avez besoin de vous nous appuyer
sur l'expérience des autres et c'est
vrai que ils ont été d'un grand conseil
pour nous ils n'ont surtout
cité à travailler dans la transparence à
établir dès le départ une relation de
confiance avec avec nos élus locaux avec
la municipalité et depuis mais les
choses sont en train d'avancer
quelles sont les difficultés justement
que vous pouvez rencontrer au quotidien
c'est justement cette question de
peut-être de transparence en tout cas
des chances permanent avec les élus et
dans un contexte particulier où il faut
sans cesse assuré quels sont les
différents besoins vous avez oui il faut
il faut effectivement sans cesse rassuré
parce que on a affaire à des gens qui
quand il s'en fassent d'actualité un peu
anxiogène auront tendance à regarder
autour d'eux avec une certaine
inquiétude et notre travail
quand responsables d'associations s'est
déjà des départs d'aller vers ces gens
là pour essayer de douala de s'ouvrir à
eux parce que finalement le travail
d'une association c'est d'abord et avant
tout ça de créer du lien
aussi bien au sein d'une communauté que
avec les communautés
même constat j'imagine peut-être il ya
quelques spécificités difficultés vous
avez pu rencontrer à la mise en place de
l'association sur 106 à fontenay oui au
tout départ
bien sûr toute association de nouvelles
on va dire en compte forcément des
difficultés et il faut un certain temps
pour le tablier on va dire de la
confiance ne serait ce qu'avec les élus
avec avec les citoyens hausse est de la
ville parce que c'est quelque chose
c'est un phénomène nouveau pour eux
d'avoir eu deux structures on va dire
musulmane ils n'ont pas encore
l'habitude
donc oui il faut un certain temps il
faut
il faut s'est montré on va dire il faut
il faut par des actions aussi valoriser
l'association qui est important donc
toutes ces choses là sont très
importants pour la confiance que vous
parliez les différents échanges avec les
élus les élus qui étaient présents lors
du dîner de ce week-end notamment benoît
hamon député socialiste de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
je vous propose de l'écouter il évoque
justement ce besoin à des changes et ce
besoin des changes mature adultes
écoutez je trouve que des fois il ya une
relation un peu paternaliste des
politiques vis-à-vis du monde musulman
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on en sorte
de cette relation paternaliste parce
qu'elle est
man n'est pas saine et cette initiative
une bonne initiative pour justement
avoir un échange dans une
peut être compliqué des échanges qui
soit différent des échanges partir
analystes peut-être quelques fois avec
les politiques vous l'avez ressenti des
fois comme ça un petit peu sur le
terrain disons que malheureusement en
fait il ya il ya quand même des
habitudes qui qui perdure qui tendent à
disparaître chez certains politiques
ça peut s'expliquer de différentes
manières pourtant le rapport entre
l'islam et la france est plus que
séculaire mais il ya toujours cette
cette méfiance donc mais cette attitude
là on l'a on la voit dans par exemple la
confiance qu'on que peuvent avoir les
politiques à ce que les musulmans
puissent s'organiser de même
donc il ya encore du travail à faire
dans ce sens là et peut-être qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait un travail
d'accompagnement dead de partage de deux
points de vue plus que 2 d'orientation
donné il ya il ya une pluralité de
l'islam en france
c'est pour ça que s'il ya débat entre la
question de l'islam de france l'islam en
france et ces questions de
représentativité ne peuvent se faire
qu'avec le travail de tous il ya une
volonté d'évolution aussi au sein du
cadre au sein de votre structure commune
qui vous réunit c'est vous même qui le
dit il faut aussi évolué parce qu'il
faut lutter contre les amalgames il faut
aussi lutter contre le radicalisme
religieux
comment vous intervenez comment vous
réfléchissez autour de l'évolution de
votre votre structure sur le radicalisme
religieux par exemple c'est quoi c'est
une un meilleur contrôle par exemple
parce que vous déplorez aussi le manque
de moyens pour pour encadrer le prêches
des imams par exemple alors pas par
rapport au radicalisme religieux bon il
faut toujours être prudent avec ces
termes là et essayer de toujours les
définir en amont mais puisque le sco ce
que l'on comprend tous par là c'est un
peu ce qui se passe dans l'actualité
depuis quelques temps notamment par
rapport à cela
ce qu'il faut c'est essayer d'analyser
comment on en arrive à là il y avait un
imam du collectif
yann un imam d'une des associations du
collectif qui lors d'une réunion donc
avec
des personnes d'autres cultes à effet
cette analyse que j'ai trouvé très
profonde
après étude de plusieurs cas et de
diagnostic fait par des sociologues lui
en était venu à une équation simple il
considérait que les principaux facteurs
de radicalisation résider en 3.1
l'ignorance sous toutes ses formes aussi
l'ignorance des textes religieux
2 le sentiment de rejet que l'on peut
que que la personne peut avoir et 3
juillet le troisième point c'était donc
la mauvaise rencontre merci merci la
mauvaise rencontre donc et ses mauvaises
rencontres justement elles se font très
très rarement voire jamais dans les
mosquées
c'est le paradoxe c'est souvent dans les
réseaux sociaux voilà et comment vous
pouvez intervenir sur ça justement
est-ce que vous avez vocation à
intervenir et en tout cas si vous le
souhaitez comment vous pouvez intervenir
mais ont cadré mieux éduqués être encore
plus présent au quotidien dans le druide
ans dans le cadre de la prévention je le
pense que chaque association a un rôle
important à jouer et ce rôle là doit le
mener avec avec l'état main dans la main
maintenant comme disait monsieur dalli
il faut déjà qu'on arrive à trouver une
définition de caisse que le radicalisme
religieux
ça peut être interprété de différentes
manières suivant les uns et les autres
est ce que le radicalisme religieux
consiste à avoir une barbe en plus
grande aux plus petites à avoir une
djellaba ou pas voilà donc on se repose
pointé du doigt c'est l'appel au djihad
le départ vers déjà on est tout seul la
série je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
on est tous d'accord là dessus on va
dire ça c'est notre point commun mais je
veux dire certains politiques
malheureusement divergent dans le mou
radicalisme et ça prête à confusion
auprès de certains nos concitoyens on
sort peut-être un peu du cadre mais on
s'achemine vers une année électorale
2017 avec des présidentielles avec la
présidentielle les législatives et s'est
vu le contexte actuel c'est quelque
chose qui vous inquiète aussi
ces amalgames qui peuvent être faits ces
problèmes de définition qui pourraient
quelquefois s'immiscer dans les débats
les stigmatiser du coup la communauté
m'a clairement parce que sauver quand
conz est en train de travailler
redonner de la confiance à des jeunes
qui va là qu'ils se sentent complètement
délaissé c'est un travail de longue
haleine c'est un travail dans lequel
vous avez besoin d'être d'être
extrêmement crédible donc vous commencé
par expliquer à des jeunes qui
effectivement s'il ya une semaine une
situation qui peut leur paraître injuste
mais que rien n'est rédhibitoire qui lie
à autour d'eux des gens qui sont prêts
les prêts à les écouter donc vous faites
ce travail là et puis vous avez une
intervention qui tombe un peu comme un
couperet et ça vous explose tout votre
travail donc c'est vrai que ça c'est
quelque chose qui nous qui nous inquiète
énormément il faut que certains
politiques comprennent que le travail
qu'on a à faire c'est un travail en
profondeur qui va demander du temps
c'est un travail qui va demander
beaucoup d'efforts et sincère vraiment
pas grand chose de venir à chaque fois
voilà tout cas c'est tout l'inversé
c'est le travail qui cassait tout le
travail
parmi le travail qui est mené il ya eu
aussi l'année dernière la mise en place
du conseil des institutions musulmanes
des yvelines j'aimerais qu'on écoute le
préfet des yvelines sur cette question
et puis je vous ferai réagir juste après
pour conclure cet entretien il ya eu la
constitution en juin 2015
du conseil des musulmans des yvelines le
simi qui se réunit
fréquemment et je suis évidemment très
souvent à ces réunions et dans lesquels
nous évoquons tous les sujets qui
concernent la communauté musulmane le
dialogue interreligieux et le dialogue
et l'action avec des services de l'état
très rapidement un an après la mise en
place de ce conseil de ceux-ci miss a
été utile c'est utile c'est encore jeune
c'est encore jeune il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on laisse le temps ou aux choses de
se faire d'une manière générale je pense
que tout type de 2,2 d'action visant à
faciliter le dialogue entre les
musulmans et les autorités est une chose
positive une chose positive qu'il faut
qu'on organise qu'on prenne le temps de
faire en concertation collective
encore une fois il est important que que
qui ait aucun sentiment de rejet et il
faut que le maximum de musulmans se
sentent représentés et donc ça prend du
temps ça se fait à un rythme qui est qui
celui qu'il est mais qui doit se faire
vu l'enjeu les enjeux qu'il ya et pour
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez je pense
que tout le monde est incontestable sur
le fait que la question de l'islam et
des musulmans va être une question qui
va être abordée dans les prochaines
sélections maintenant ce qu'il faut
c'est que par certains propos on ne
provoque pas aussi la radicalisation
mais justement alors peut-être pour
conclure cette question liée à
l'actualité parce que en france une
polémique qui enfle ces derniers jours
c'est les grandes enseignes populaires
qui commercialisent et des vêtements
islamiques quels sont vos avis sur ça ce
que vous avez un avis un regard parce
que là on stigmatise le port de ces
vêtements et forcément on se tourne vers
la définition de la radicalisation par
exemple est ce que voit la porte et le
type des vêtements ça peut être
considéré comme un signe de
radicalisation mois ci nous sommes un
pays capitaliste donc c'est le libre de
libre échange et
la fête de marles les mines autour de ça
après c'est une polémique je laisse la
polémique aux polémiques heures très
bien merci à tous les trois d'être
revenu sur ce plateau pour évoquer
notamment ce dîner annuel du collectif
des associations musulmanes de saint
quentin et des alentours parce que ça va
beaucoup plus loin merci à tous les
trois nous poursuivons ce journal il
officiait depuis cinq ans à la tête de
la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique des yvelines jean
marie salanova officiellement quitté ses
fonctions le 8 avril vendredi dernier
une réception était organisée vous le
voyez en préfecture à versailles pour
son départ le préfet a souligné
l'efficacité de son action il a rappelé
la baisse significative de l'insécurité
de l'eau dans le département ces
dernières années jean-marie salanova est
muté au même poste mais à marseille dans
les bouches du rhône ont beaucoup nous
avons réussi à faire baisser la
délinquance
nous avons réussi à élucider beaucoup
plus d'affaires de délinquance lorsque
je suis arrivé dans ce département le
taux d'élucidation des affaires était à
32 %
jean par le taux d'élucidation des
affaires est à 41% et demi
l'organisation des services le
fonctionnement au quotidien
c'est une remise permanente de l'
ouvrage sur le métier et par voie de
conséquence je pars avec de grandes
satisfactions mais je sais que je laisse
à mes successeurs de grandes
possibilités d'amélioration encore de ce
qui a été construit pour recueillis par
camille lambert premier volet à présent
de notre reportage consacré à anaïs
anaïs c'est cette petite fille de
plaisir cinq ans elle est atteinte de
tetra paresys est une forme et
d'infirmité moteur cérébral qui se
traduit par une paralysie des quatre
membres à handicap qui a bouleversé la
vie de ses parents également qui tente
de lui donner le plus de chances
possibles pour qu'elles puissent accéder
enfin à l'autonomie elle est suivie a
notamment par l'hôpital raymond poincaré
à garches et ses parents lui font aussi
pratiqué plusieurs méthodes de
rééducation dites alternatives un
engagement coûteux qui les a poussés à
créer une association anaïs du rêve à
l'espoir pour les aider au financement
de tous ces soins premier volet du
reportage que nous lui consacrons donc
ce soir réalisé par william l
tout le monde était là à la haye à
alexandre il n'est pas marqué avec
centre à cinq ans à sa naissance un
manque d'oxygène à créer des lésions
cérébrales conduisant à une tetra paresi
une forme d'infirmité moteur cérébral la
petite fille est suivi par plusieurs
praticiens à l'hôpital raymond-poincaré
de garches
aujourd'hui après l'école elle a rendez
vous avec laeticia sont légaux
thérapeute qui la suit depuis trois ans
c'est une petite fille qui présentent de
grandes difficultés motrices de grosses
difficultés de coordination motrice sur
l'ensemble du corps y compris sur la
sphère bucco faciale une des priorités
aussi chez cette petite ça c'est de
pouvoir pouvoir s'exprimer elle pouvoir
communiquer avec son entourage
l'objectif de ces séances d'ergothérapie
rendre autonomes et indépendantes la
petite fille dans les activités de la
vie quotidienne
jeudi 7 mars
jeudi 7 avril jeudi 7 avril pour ces
séances
anaïs utilise une synthèse vocale une
tablette qui permet à l'enfant de
communiquer et d'avoir de vraies
conversations
en fait ça des combinaisons de
pictogrammes qui vont nous permettre
d'aller dans différents différents
registres
on va pouvoir conjuguer tous les verbes
à cet endroit là toute la ligne du haut
ça va être
des catégories les habits les animaux la
nourriture
voilà on va voir tous les petits mots de
liaison qui vont être en verre etc le
fait d'apprendre toutes les combinaisons
des pictogrammes qui
qui va pouvoir permettre une
conversation après fonctionnel avec des
mots de liaison avec on peut enregistrer
des phrases on peut faire plein plein de
choses et on peut tout dire surtout un
appareil qui coûte de 8000 euros mais
indispensable à la petite fille pour lui
permettre de mieux communiquer en marche
de l'école
anaïs suit des séances d'orthophonie
kinésithérapie ergothérapie ainsi que
divers soins à l'hôpital des semaines
très lourde pour une petite fille pleine
de vie
comme chaque lundi nous avons une page
que le tueur à présent avec sephora
nahman bonsoir sephora cette page
culture il est question d'un projet
éducatif mené avec les élèves de cm1 de
l'école marcel pagnol de coignières
c'est un projet pilote en france
exactement en janvier dernier je vous
avais présenté ce projet artistique et
culturel mené avec ses élèves de
coignières en partenariat avec le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
et le photographe professionnel frédéric
grah installé à elancourt alors pour
faire simple il s'agissait d'apprendre
aux enfants à se servir d'un appareil
photographique réflexe écouter keymi
paillardes institutrice un projet p acc
et un projets éducatifs artistiques et
culturelles qui est réalisé par
l'enseignant qui choisit une structure
partenaire et un intervenant pour
essayer d'ouvrir les enfants à un
univers culturel inconnu où justement
sur un univers sur lequel il a envie de
travailler
nous en tant qu'enseignant on travaille
beaucoup en histoire de l'art sur la
peinture sur le dessin mais très peu sur
la photographie
donc je trouvais ça intéressant aussi
que les enfants puissent découvrir leur
environnement autrement en apprenant
observé alors les élèves ont bénéficié
de quinze ateliers pour ce projet
répartis en deux groupes lors des
séances une partie travailler la théorie
en histoire de l'art l'autre travaille
la pratique avec le photographe
professionnel frédéric grah chacun des
minots m'avait son appareil photo pour
travailler en fonction du thème sur les
différents types de cadrage ou encore
les réglages tels que les iso
l'ouverture et la vitesse d'obturation
des appareils photos qui sont aussi gros
que la tête de ses enfants c'est assez
rigolo à la fin d'été un atelier mise en
pratique c'était lors d'un séjour à la
montagne
on refuse rien c'est ça ils ont de la
chance alors les enfants sont partis
deux semaines dans les hautes-alpes en
janvier dernier à saint michel de mayol
et chaque matinée était dévolue à la
mise en pratique de la photographie en
prenant en compte les contraintes
de l'environnement liés aux
réfléchissement de la lumière sur la
neige et la montagne en général et ce
n'était pas si facile apparemment j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt dur parce qu' il
fallait arriver à choisir ce qu'on
allait prendre en photo faire les bons
réglages pour pouvoir que voir que la
photo n'est pas flou quelle qu'elles ne
soient pas trop lumineuse et pas trop
foncée quand même j'avais pris le
télésiège parce que je voulais montrer
représenter le ski et tout en gardant
que la montagne derrière une vision
d'artiste comme les professionnels
maintenant il présente ses différents
clichés avec une exposition
oui les enfants sont très fiers
d'exposer jusqu'à la fin du mois chacun
leurs clichés alors au total une
trentaine de clichés dans le hall de la
mairie de coignières des paysages des
portraits des mises en scène un travail
précis sur la même luminosité et de
vraies propositions artistiques avec des
jeux au niveau de la profondeur de champ
pour créer des nets et des flous en
figeant l'instant ils ont dû apprendre à
observer et porter un nouveau regard sur
leur environnement
l'institutrice et le photographe sont
satisfaits du résultat à tel point que
le projet sera renouvelée l'année
prochaine avec une autre classe et
autour de la thématique du portrait
cette fois ci les ont repris ce rire
précise donc que c'est un atelier pilote
en france il y en a très peu de ce type
de projet avec photographie et mise en
pratique merci sephora on continue à
parler culture pour conclure ce journal
samedi avait lieu l'inauguration de la
tour du donjon de houdan rénové sous
l'impulsion de jean marie têtards qui le
député maire de cette commune les
travaux sont enfin achevé après quatre
ans de chantier pour l'occasion les élus
du département ont fait le déplacement
valérie pécresse on quand gérard larcher
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude érigé au 12e siècle le donjon
de houdan est le symbole de l'origine
médiéval de la ville avec ses murs
d'enceinte ses tours de guet sa rue des
fossés ancien relais d'étape au cours du
temps le donjon inconnu différents
usages de la prison au réservoir d'eau
celui ci vient d'être restauré après
quatre ans de travaux on en a rêvé on
l'a fait c'est une aventure dans
laquelle il fallait réunir à la fois des
financements pour celui charges très
lourd pour notre commune et puis à ne
pas se tromper de projet à la fois faire
une réhabilitation archéologiques mais
qui soit compatible avec des usages
modernes visite touristique compte comme
soeur etc
l'inauguration du donjon a élu et samedi
9 avril d'un coût global de plus d'un
million 3 le projet de restauration a
été subventionné par le département la
commune à hauteur de 800 mille euros et
la région ile de france
celle ci souhaite soutenir la culture en
zones rurales dans lesquelles deux
millions de franciliens habite il est
question de favoriser l'accès à la
culture en restaurant le patrimoine pour
en faire de nouveaux lieux
d'attractivité si on y fait venir de la
culture et de la vie culturelle et bien
forcément l'animent les centres-villes
et forcément on dynamise le commerce de
proximité on remet de la vie dans les
villages et tout mon projet aujourd'hui
c'est d'essayer de permettre aux
franciliens d'avoir de la ville là où il
habite de travailler au plus près de là
où ils habitent de se déplacer le moins
possible éviter ce côté village dortoir
que l'on rencontre aujourd'hui dans la
très grande couronne classé monument
historique en 1886 le donjon millénaire
de houdan a encore de beaux jours devant
lui c'est sur ces images que nous
refermons ce journal dans quelques
instants le point sur l'actualité
sportive avec le 7-8 sport présenté
préparé par michael et demi d'euros
parmi ses invités a dit lahm houmadi les
longs courtois qui vient de perdre son
titre de champion d'europe des poids
super moyens je vous retrouve demain
pour un nouveau journal très bonne
soirée